sunrise chicken cooking thanks so much
[Music]
this guy does not give a [ __ ] all right
all right i'll give you something
i don't know if i should i don't know if
i should
but i will does it like spinach
yeah hungry little guy
where is he that [ __ ] might jump
up on me
oh my god he's so close
maybe he likes some of that spinach
again
y'all gonna kiss
why you gotta make out right in front of
my van dude
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are these things
why are they so familiar with humans
they know i ain't gonna kill them or do
[Music]
they
get out of here
[Music]
hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] they [ __ ] at my fire pit
because they're mad i didn't give them
[Music]
food
here i am walking bare feet
on the road to the hills
there's my little van
and there is expanse of the desert
if i can't get a fair exchange rate for
my survival on the free market of
capitalism
then i'm gonna create my own
life away from that cycle and part of
that
involves not having an apartment
so relaxing
i'm so relaxed right now
this is a dune dan
going up a dune
i made it
it's been five days since i last saw a
human
and two hours still ask how to drop a
water
life is tough out here in the dunes
the sand is all-encompassing
and it destroys any sense of uh
stability in the world i'm going mad out
here
i haven't even kissed a boob
in five hours uh here in the dunes
the sand and everywhere it's everywhere
and it's hot
and stuff and i'm struggling help
i'm in trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we finally got it all right
[Music]
i have with me a bong and inside this
bowl of the bong
is a bit of marijuana uh which is a
schedule one narcotic according to the
department of uh enforcement of drugs
drug enforcement
agency the dea what's up roger kittens
it's hans kim here here's a tour of my
van i try to stitch this up
but it's coming apart um
i guess uh you know men are inferior in
some ways
i have a sharpened stick which i like to
think offers me some sort of security
but uh
it's kind of chipped away at the tip
i got an ukulele
so on this drawer we have
my water tank and my neck pillow this is
a lifesaver
you gotta have this if you're a van
lifey come on let me show you in the
back
come on let me show you in the back
emergency emergency mosquito mosquito
and now i'm safe and nothing can hurt me
ever again
it looks like i'm i'm a victorian lady
and i'm just dainty and i need like
little frills around my bed to make me
feel safe
oh look there's something more
vulnerable and softer than me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you